JOINING US NOW FROM WASHINGTON
WHERE YOU GUYS ALL USUALLY ARE
IS TUCKER CARLSON.
TUCKER, GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US
.
YOU'RE OBSERVATION SO FAR.
>> THE FLORIDA RACE IS AMAZING.
I WOULD ADD IT'S NOT JUST
REPUBLICANS WHO THOUGHT ANDREW
GILLUM WOULD BE EASY TO KNOCK
OFF.
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS IN WASHINGTO
WERE CONVINCED THEY WOULD NEVER
WIN THIS SEAT WITH HIM RUNNING.
THERE WERE PRIMARIES ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE AS WELL.
HERE WAS A GUY WHO WAS IN SOME
WAY IMPLICATED IN AN FBI
INVESTIGATION AND WOULD NOT
EXPLAINED THAT.
HE CALLED ANYBODY WHO QUESTIONE
HIM RACIST FOR ASKING.
THE ONE-TIME MAYOR OF
TALLAHASSEE 126 LARGEST CITY IN
AMERICA AND RUNNING ON A
PLATFORM ON APOLOGY TO KEELEY
LEFT WING.
IF HE WINS FLORIDA FIRST THERE'
IMPLICATIONS AS YOU KNOW FOR
THAT PRESIDENTIAL RACE,  BUT
MUCH DEEPER IMPLICATIONS FOR
BOTH PARTIES.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN EXACTLY?
DISSENT IS MAYBE WASN'T THE
STRONGEST CAPTAIN AT IT, BUT TH
FACT IS IF GILLUM GLANCE, THAT
RAISES A LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT
WOULD SAY THERE'S PROBABLY TWO
ANSWERS.
IT'S THE OBVIOUS.
IMMIGRATION AND THE ECONOMY.
IMMIGRATION HAS CHANGED FLORIDA.
IN A RECOGNIZABLE WAY.
THE CALIFORNIA AVENUE 30 YEARS
AGO WAS SOLIDLY REPUBLICAN AND
SO WAS FLORIDA.
NOW AN DIFFERENT PEOPLE ARE
LIVING IN THEM.
THAT HAS TAKEN PLACE BENEATH TH
NOTICE OF MOST PEOPLE PAYING
ATTENTION.
THE SECOND IS THE ECONOMY WHICH
IS WEAKER IN WAYS THAN WE IN
WASHINGTON DON'T PERCEIVE.
THE CONVENTIONAL GDP AND MARKET
PERFORMANCE.
BOTH OF THEM ARE GREAT.
IF YOU LIKE IT UNDER OTHER
INDICATORS YOU SEE THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF POOR PEOPLE.
THE SINGLE MOST COMMON LIVING
ARRANGEMENT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
RIGHT NOW IS WITH THEIR PARENTS.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN A
TIME AFTER THE INDUSTRIAL
REVOLUTION WHEN THAT'S BEEN TRU
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT MEANS THAT QUESTIONS LIKE
HEALTH CARE ARE MUCH MORE REAL
THAN THEY HAVE BEEN EVEN THREE
CYCLES AGO.
REPUBLICANS WON 63 SEATS IN THE
2010 MIDTERM ON THE BACK OF
OBAMACARE.
ANDREW GILLUM PROPOSING
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE IN EFFECT
MEDICAID FOR ALL WHICH HE HAS I
WRITTEN OFF AS MOST PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON AS A PIPE DREAM AND
THINK IS A MATHEMATICAL QUESTION
.
IT IS LUDICROUS, THERE'S NO WAY
TO PAY FOR THAT,  BUT IT
RESONATES WITH THE STATE THAT'S
POORER THAN IT LOOKS.
I THINK IS REPUBLICANS THINK
ABOUT HOW DID THIS HAPPEN, HOW
DID SOMEONE WHO'S NOT AS
IMPRESSIVE AS YOU WOULD IMAGINE
GOVERNOR OF A MAJOR STATE WOULD
NEED TO BE, HOW DID HE WIN?
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO THINK
THROUGH IT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING
HERE.
NOTHING WITH RUSSIA OR STORMI
DANIELS, THERE'S REAL STUFF
GOING ON.
>> I THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
I ALSO THINK HE'S BUILT A
GRASSROOTS CAMPAIGN FROM THE
BEGINNING.
HE ARRIVED ON THE SCENE AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE
HIS APPEAL, I THINK THAT'S ALSO
SOMETHING THAT I'M KIND OF
WATCHING IN TERMS OF THE TREND
OF THE EVENING.
CHARISMATIC, APPEALING
CANDIDATES APPEAR TO BE DOING
FAIRLY WELL WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> I WOULD ARGUE IN THIS CASE
THEY DIDN'T.
I DON'T THINK IF YOU HAD
ASSEMBLED A GROUP OF 20
DEMOCRATIC POLITICAL CONSULTANT
IN DC AND SAID DRAW YOUR DREAM
CANDIDATE I DON'T THINK IT
WOULD'VE BEEN GILLUM.
THEY PROBABLY WANTED SOMEBODY
THAT LOOKED LIKE HIM AND HAVE
THE MANNER, BUT I DON'T THINK
THEY WOULD WORK SOMEONE WITH TH
HARD LEFT POLITICS OF GILLUM.
THEY THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO
LOSE.
I THINK MAYBE THE HARD LEFT
ECONOMIC ISSUES ARE A LITTLE
MORE POPULAR THAN WE WANT TO
THINK THEY ARE.
I THINK THAT'S OMINOUS, BUT IT
DOESN'T MAKE IT ANY LESS TRUE.
WHY IS IT THAT THEY DON'T WORK
FOR EXAMPLE.
WILL PROBABLY LOSE TONIGHT, BUT
HE'S COMING A LOT CLOSER THAN I
SHOULD BE IN THE STATE OF TEXAS.